over the weekend was looking into some
things and um you know I've been
sounding like a bear you know the bear
and the bull and the bear is down on the
market the bull is optimistic about the
market and um people say you've been
sounding like a bear I don't mean to be
I'm just a weatherman I'm looking at the
charts and if it says rain I say rain if
it says tornado I say tornado and if it
says hurricane I say get out of town
until the storms passed but that's what
I've been seeing it so I am at heart a
bull at heart I am an optimist I believe
entrepreneurs are the solution to so
many things in America and I believe we
can do it so that's where I live but
what I've been seeing is a lot of stats
that are saying rain is coming and right
now some of the rain is here so about
the mortgage and real estate market over
the past year I want to take you through
something Dave I think is a really
shocking stat but first let's do the
building blocks of what has been going
on because we've been talking about this
on the yeah pbd podcast right we've been
in a conversation for the last couple
years so there's no surprise here on our
end at least exactly so first of all we
know that printing a bunch of money all
those stimulus checks people don't know
that causes asset inflation what's asset
inflation cars cost more some of you saw
that even used cars cost more and never
mind what was the part they were always
trying to get that was a shortage
semiconductor chips that's right yeah a
few chips chips control your air
conditioning your GPS everything
everything else so there was all that
that had nothing to do with it that was
just a shortage that was also causing
problems with during covid and shipping
Parts the underlying asset cars were
going up real estate was going up so the
printing money caused that so the first
issue we have in the building blocks was
housing prices went up like 25 to 40
percent all across the USA down here in
South Florida we're down here in Fort
Lauderdale even crazier even crazier
completely and so suddenly people
couldn't afford homes and the market
started slowing 2022 a little bit for
sales and then what happened beginning
in 2022 all of a sudden we had interest
rates and interest rates were under
three percent in other words you and I
were going down to Wells Fargo and
everything to get ourselves a loan for
the house and we were getting 2.75 3.25
3.5 depending on our credit that was the
beginning of 2022 in January and then
the FED went crazy right they went
ballistic yeah exactly like a kid with a
credit card with no limit that's exactly
right and every six weeks the Fed was
quarter point quarter point quarter
point until interest rates had doubled
to 7 in October of 2022. now that's only
about six months ago and right now how
many what was that
how many times in a row the FED raise
rates it's like 10 times in a row 10 10
times in a row the FED raise rates so
everybody's waiting interest rates going
down they're going to stay flat the FED
Jerome Powell raise it again well what
did that do that's what lifted up the
everything that was going on so now you
had homes more expensive for people
trying to buy them and then when they
went to the bank the mortgage was gonna
the payment was going to be higher
because now interest rates were seven if
they could even still get qualified
right or they had to go
they can only afford a five hundred
thousand dollar house now that house is
650 they can't afford that now they got
to go find something for 500 but now
they can't afford that because now the
interest rates up the payment's going to
be higher now they have to find that
place for 450 and they're finding small
houses or things guess what the whole
Market slows down you see what I just
described there that is a factual
analysis of what happened to the average
American running through this so the
market slows and so everybody's asking
are the rates going to drop where are
they going to go well the FED forecast
and there's a whole bunch of these
acronyms that you hear all the time if
you read The Wall Street Journal
you'll see them all the time and you'll
you can go to all sorts of news stories
you'll be reading something all of a
sudden the sacrament and one of the
things is there is sofr secured
overnight financing rate data all that
means is what are the averages looking
like what is the weather forecast for
interest rates and there's two to look
at one is the market
does what's called betting on Futures so
the market you can tell what the market
thinks is going to happen to interest
rates and then you have a Fed forecast
and I think we have a chart on that and
so Angel we got the the chart here the
black line and the yellow line let's
talk a little about these lines and
let's show them to them so if you're
watching at at home or you're driving in
a car I'll drive I'll describe this for
you and if you can see it follow along
the black dotted line is what the FED
believes is where we're going and what
you can see is 2023 you can see it
thinks it's going to be flat and then in
January of 2024
we are going to see rates going down and
finally get back to three percent at the
end of 25. well wait a minute wait a
minute we're sitting here almost halfway
through 23 and you're saying flat for a
while and then dropping down getting the
three percent by the end of 25
that's not good news now the market
thinks that that's was going to be a
little bit more aggressive and matter of
fact the market is worried that here in
June that it's not a done deal next week
that the FED will not raise interest
rates that there might be a quarter
point raise or maybe one in July before
it goes down so the market was thinking
that the FED would come down a little
bit quicker and that affect a pretty big
drop at the beginning of 24. well now
the FED forecast thinks no I don't think
so now why do they think that because
they're getting bad news they're seeing
wages are up now to the FED trying to
control inflation wages go up mean
inflation is not calming down and the
FED wants to get inflation back for two
percent so all the things that you and I
buy food energy heating oil in the
Northeast a lot of electricity in
Phoenix for your air conditioners that
all that kind of calms down so that it's
less expensive to live
and so we've got everyone here thinks
it's going to be two years till we get
the interest rates back down to where
they were a year and three months ago at
the beginning of 22 that it's going to
be two years until they get back there
and
when you listen to the fed and you see
those and we've been making fun of
Jerome Powell right yeah he's he's
telling my tell my little story about
him about the cheerleaders yeah the U.S
economy is a cheerleader and every time
Jerome Powell heads upstairs and bangs
the cheerleader he is pounding the
economy well what he's trying to pound
is inflation but it also ends up having
another effect on your mortgage's credit
card interest rates everything else and
they say well it's a necessary evil to
get all these things back into balance
okay
so I built that up for you to explain
why the housing and the mortgage
industry is having such a hard time
houses are still expensive mortgage
rates are still high and it's making the
whole Market slow and Along Comes not so
shocking news you ready for this
consumer bankruptcies are suddenly up
um we were looking at year-over-year
stats like year over year what was it
yeah it's like 20 some 20 percent
personal bankruptcies are up 20 percent
year over year not twenty percent of
Americans declaring bankruptcies the
number of bankruptcies from a year ago
to now is up 20 percent we also saw that
total credit cards in this country have
hit one trillion dollars of balances in
the middle of covid after the stimulus
checks route it was only 650 only 650 to
700 billion dollars all those things
come together and we suddenly have the
upswing of home prices upswing of
mortgage interest rates
and
this crazy stat I set this whole thing
up to bring this to you
the demand survey came out
and for the people that bought a home in
2022 or the first quarter of 2023.
just we just finished first quarter
62 percent of those buyers at least one
payment was either missed or they had to
use savings account in other words their
paycheck and what they were earning and
what that cost them to live was not
enough they had to dip into savings to
make up the Gap and make the mortgage
payment which is usually the largest
payment that they have in in their
budget
or ready for this they actually use the
credit card cash advance or convenience
checks that they send you the credit
card you know they send you like this
three emergency checks yeah you can just
write State Farm on it and pay your
insurance if you had to like if you're
unemployed for a while and you had to
find a way to do that but 62 percent of
the people that bought houses in 2002
and first quarter
2023 2022 2023 they actually had to do
that for one payment so far because
inflation is pinching them and they were
probably not prepared for the property
tax rates and other things now Banks
should be evaluating you before they
give you the mortgage but there were
mortgage brokers that were pushing
qualifications to the edge because they
had to do something you know what they
had to do they had to get homes for
their clients yeah and they had to eat
because if they didn't if they didn't
sell a mortgage they don't eat that's
how they make money and a lot of that
went down so they weren't making as much
money as so what ends up with this is
scary bankruptcies up 20 62 so if you're
out there and you're having trouble God
bless you I hope you can serve this
happen now is it time to be very
conservative and to be in control now we
like to talk to a lot of small business
owners and we like because a lot of you
are watching you know entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs leaders around you know
you're you're watching all this and now
is the time to live as conservative as
you can and that's what's necessary we
need people to
um you know for your own benefit just to
take it easy and if you're running a
business keep the expenditures down but
be opportunistic about your business you
may be able to pick up business from
somebody across town that's having a
tougher time than you and absorb that
you may be able to grow and the way you
do it is be conservative and prepared
everything you do because in your Market
you may be the last man standing
um like in your town unfortunately and
we don't wish hardship fun people but
like I say the weather says it's going
to rain and if you've got a rain jacket
and common sense you're going to do
better than others
foreign